foreign
is the latest game from Arcane Austin
and we recently went hands on with it uh
I'm Lucy James I'm joined by Jake Decker
hello and tomorrow
right Lads so this is an upcoming uh
vampire Co-op
uh first person shooter open world thing
uh from Arcane which is a bit of a
departure from what they are usually
known for but want to get uh so we
played a couple hours of it we only
played in single player though so can't
really speak to the co-op nature of it
just yet but we did manage to get
Hands-On and so we're going to share
some initial Impressions
um I think the first and the easiest
place to jump off
is how arcane is this game uh I think
it's pretty arcane like everything comes
with a uh the caveat that we had a
limited selection of the game to play I
think the I wrote this in my preview but
the most concerning thing going into it
was that it ticked a lot of boxes for
games that everyone is trying to make
currently or we know that our kind of
success kind of factors in most game
design and it also has things that are
like to me tiresome
um kind of like the the kind of blue
issue a style thing where I'm like oh
God this is this is exactly what I don't
want from Arcane so the question has
been
is it an Arcane game and I personally
feel like it is from the little that
I've played definitely an Arcane game in
terms of allowing creativity encouraging
um kind of uh exploration and also a
sense of place um those are the some of
the fundamentals of an Arcane game and
we'll get into the the kind of character
stuff a bit later but the way the
characters
um play is definitely looks like and
feels very similar to us the power set
in something like a Dishonored
um uh or even some some of the abilities
that you get in death Loop or the things
that you could do and the Synergy
between them is going to definitely
create some opportunity for creativity
so from that perspective I definitely
think it feels like an Arcane game it
remains to be seen whether it's a great
Arcane game I think as well what was
very interesting for me is that
obviously Gunplay is uh much more of a
focus in redfall compared to
I mean maybe with the exception of death
Loop uh Jake how did you how did you
find that and how did you do you enjoy
the guns and stuff it felt fine I feel
like there wasn't a whole lot of
tweaking I was able to do with the
sensitivity and the dead zones and stuff
it it felt a little off
um but that seems small I think in the
grand scheme of things like that stuff
that you know we could see in the full
game there could be more settings to
tweak and change
um but one thing I did really appreciate
about the Gunplay is that the vampires
you fight you can't actually kill a gun
so you have to come up with a creative
way to kill them whether that be light
them on fire uh I don't remember if
electrocuting kills them but um you know
you had to use different environments or
you could just walk up to him with a
stake attached to your gun and stick it
in their heart and I feel like that
added a nice wrinkle to the gun play
that I wasn't quite expecting I was a
little worried it might just be a
Mindless sort of you know shooter shoot
all the enemies wait until the health
bar goes away but you actually have to
get up in there which is kind of neat
yeah especially as you're running around
because obviously so redfall is not just
it's not just endless vampires walking
around they are worshiped uh by a bunch
of cultists which kind of reminded me a
lot of death Loop actually uh you know
these kind of instead of Visionaries
you've got these uh evil kind of
demigod-esque Empires super powerful
that everyone is kind of rallying around
and the cultists who are kind of doing
their every bidding
um and so I I really enjoy the fact that
you do have to stake them to to kill
them because you could just pick off the
minions you know the human minions very
easily but then kind of provided like a
little bit of a tactical
um layer to it but the one thing I will
say is that the very first thing I did
in redfall and this is gonna be the
hardest thing I think to unlearn or
unshackle myself from as a big
Dishonored fan is the very first thing I
did is I left the firehouse which is the
sort of safe Zone safe area found a
cultist snuck up behind him pressed
right bumper and uh didn't do anything
and uh oh no I think I activated one of
my powers and then uh they turned around
and killed me because I was just that's
the part where I really hope that there
is obviously stealth in it but
everything's kind of like remapped and
the way that we got to experience the
game was like we missed the very
beginning of it they kind of plunked us
in an hour or so into the game and so I
want to be able to uncouple myself from
Dishonored rules which I know so well
which I know that a lot of Arcane fans
know very well because obviously they
you take more of a stealthy approach to
stuff one of the weird things about the
stealth 2 that I noticed at least I
couldn't find like a takedown uh a
button to press to stab them in the
throat whatever it might be you just
sneak up behind them and Bash them with
your gun and that felt a little off
especially coming from Dishonored like
you're saying where you know corvo pulls
out his blade and knifes him in the
throat
um so that felt a little bit strange
I think I think that it does kind of
make sense to a in a way that if you
think about it the game is primarily
designed around Co-op you can definitely
play it single player and even stealth
as a as in a single player scenario is
viable I use it to like get into areas
without starting big gun fights and if
you're playing someone like Jacob he's
got like clocks and stuff like that that
can get him in and out but you know
everything that we uh from everything
that we played in our discussion with um
members of the team they are their main
concern or their main kind of Drive is
to make this a co-op focused game and in
that scenario stuff like stealth
takedowns are probably not going to be
conducive to an enjoyable experience one
because no one's really going to be
slowly going in into a scenario and
playing Co-op stealth and if you're the
kind of person who is trying to do that
and then someone else shoots a gun
nearby like what does the game do does
it react to them and blow yourself and
ruin that for you so it does make sense
that it's not trying to push stealth as
a core system to to kind of like
dispatch enemies and instead as a way to
like get set up and almost get ambushes
um ready that's what I did I like snuck
into a few places like got around one of
the um like the under bosses and in a
position that would be advantageous to
me and then use that opportunity to kind
of like start wreaking havoc in in the
area let's do some recap
I would love to perform more stealth as
a person who loves stealth and loves
Arcane stealth as well but it does make
sense to me that it's not the Crux of it
um they want you to choose yeah I know
we can talk about powers and abilities
and stuff too because I I so we'll play
different characters I played Layla
um who has a kind of Shield that she can
use she also has a spectral elevator
which gets you to High Ground I I
believe if you're playing Co-op you can
get your teammates up there too that was
really fun because I would just call the
elevator shoot up somewhere kick off a
bunch of people with um a sniper rifle
and then come back down and then her
sort of ultimate ability is her vampire
ex-boyfriend comes and he basically
takes a bunch of aggro and does a deals
a bunch of damage for a limited amount
of time and I really I really liked her
move set but who did you guys play what
did you think
I played Jacob because his name was
Jacob and I was like you know yeah I
gotta go for it uh I I enjoyed it
because he was a little more stealth
focused um with his ability to cloak and
one cool thing like kind of to what you
were saying earlier tomorrow is that uh
in Co-op that ability extends to your
teammates I think if they're nearby
which is something we didn't get to test
out but like that's kind of cool I like
being the I like the idea of being the
stealth guy who helps other people
stealth through levels or you know just
set up ambushes but on that he's got a
sniper rifle that deals a lot of damage
from afar I I enjoyed playing as him I
think he he didn't really have any good
Mobility stuff at least that that I
found I ended up switching to a
different character who had a blink like
ability which tomorrow I imagine you're
going to talk about but I think I ended
up preferring that other character just
because I could blink and teleport and
and you know there was there was a
traversal element that I feel like I
didn't really have with Jacob yeah I
played as davinda and he's like this
cryptozoologist who's been on the
internet for a bit too long and has got
like theories and and knows all this
weird [__] about vampires and also has
like put together these tools that help
him fight vampires so like Jake said I
did have that teleport ability which is
it's not like something like um the
blink in Dishonored voice like magical
or Supernatural it's just this device
where he lets him translocate but you
can use it in a similar way where you
like Chuck it across you know
um a gap between two buildings and then
teleport across over or like up onto
roofs and that kind of stuff it's it has
limited range but it's still good enough
you can like do a very high jump and
then throw it and teleport just before
you land to negate all all the damage
that you might get from a
um a drop but beyond that he's got this
like he's got the ability to like put
down these pylons almost like you can
use them to shock
um enemies and like uh keep them in
place and then he's got another one
which way he puts it down and it like
sends out a blast of I think it's
ultraviolet light and that turns all the
vampires into stone
um and you can like do way more damage
and if you get up close you can break
some of them as well um so it's almost
like an instant kill but the the harder
bigger vampires um they're a bit more
resistant to it and they will also break
out of it a bit quicker so I think
davinder was a good
opportunity for me to kind of get a good
taste of different different types of um
uh combat you can approach and it worked
he worked well because I could go in and
out of stealth but also be super
offensive and also have that Mobility so
I think it's a pretty interesting
character and like we talked about a lot
of I think the the weird thing is like
the things that we're talking about
sound very ordinary compared to what we
expect out of
um a a Arcane game right it sounds like
we're just describing another games as
obviously a shooter but the using those
abilities is way more interesting than
anything I've done in say Borderlands or
whatever it may be
um and I haven't played enough Destiny
to say the same thing but like it's that
kind of vibe where it's like the more
you use it the better you understand it
and then you can figure out how to like
kind of push the the limits of those
abilities and like we said we didn't
play co-op but I think that's where a
lot of the mileage is going to be like
how does davinder's abilities you know
collaborate with Layla and what
strengths does Layla have that the
window doesn't and how do we work
together and once you get multiple
people I feel like it's the potential is
going to be in how those all those
abilities intersect to create a bigger
Cooperative Arcane experience if you
know yeah yeah well one thing I want to
add about davinder that I found out too
is that you can also transport enemies
with your little trans locator thing so
I would transport enemies into hazards a
lot and I've had a lot of fun doing that
so I I'm excited to see like you're
saying like how you can kind of push
these abilities in different ways and
then on top of that there's that other
layer of how can you combine these
different abilities with different uh
characters and different players that I
think could make for some really
interesting uh combinations
yeah
and obviously another thing about
redfull is the world is so much bigger
than anything we've ever seen from
Arcane and like in our time with it I
was kind of pleasantly surprised because
you kind of have the usual open World
stuff of unlocking safe houses unlocking
fast travel side quests there was one in
particular in that very opening area
that definitely caught my attention I
won't say any more than that but if
you're an Arcane fan you will notice it
immediately pretty much I
um I was kind of worried because one of
the things I love about the worlds that
Arcane build is that they are they feel
like actual places they have
rules to them they have history and I
was kind of worried about redfull
um not having that just because by by
way of being a giant open world and you
would lose some of those smaller stories
and some of that history but I didn't
I'm glad to say that's not the case I
thought what was really interesting
about it is that obviously there is
there are these Open Spaces
um and enough room for the other people
that you would be playing with but also
when you get to Interiors or certain
places certain exteriors there was all
of that lovely environmental
storytelling that I really enjoyed and
there's one bit in the in the main
mission that we were playing and you
kind of
uh going to this person's uh kind of
mansion and you you know it's obviously
locked down you have to kind of get in
and like just going around walking I was
like oh this is our cake this is Arcane
stuff absolutely but I would worry that
if I was
playing that with other people and
secretly I was kind of glad when they
said there was only going to be single
player because I wanted to check that
out
um I would be worried that a lot of
stuff would be missed not everyone is
the meticulous
note to Rita that say I am or tammys or
Jake you are like and I think would be
interesting getting the balance of that
group but World wise
um how did you find it was there
anything in particular that surprised
you about the world that uh the kind of
Arcane have made here any
any potential issues yeah I think they
they when we talked to
um when we talked to Ricardo he was very
upfront about the fact that the
narrative Ambitions for this game are
quite different from the narrative
Ambitions for say like a Dishonored
death Loop or even prey where that
they're not trying to take one character
or two characters if you count corvo and
Emily
um and and tell their story it's more a
case of like telling the story through
events and actions and that kind of
stuff so I was similarly worried where
you know I was wondering like how am I
gonna play this you know and absorb
these stories while there are other
people around and the way I'm gonna do
that is by playing on my own for a
little bit but also like it's not that
it's not as critical to it and what they
seem to have done is like hey tell the
stories but tell them in a way that it
doesn't require you to play you know to
be absolute focused on it instead a lot
of that story is told through like the
environments themselves and using how
it's set up and interesting visuals to
tell that story story and then having
the character say short and sweet things
that get the point across very quickly
and then move on and let you kind of
like have the experience of moving
around redfall taking out vampires and
doing it together be the the overall Arc
of the story itself
um and like you said they definitely
seem to have figured out what works for
them in that they do have you know these
open World areas that are a little more
Barren but what they do there is like
they put interesting enemy kind of
skirmishes for you to engage in if you
want to but when you get into a key area
um it does have that density of detail
and and kind of like the the
thoughtfulness that you expect from an
Arcane environment at least here like
like as we said we played the what they
described or
um Ricardo called the tutorial area and
there's going to be more districts that
open up
um but the little that we played
definitely had it yeah one thing I will
say I guess this kind of fits into World
design but two
I don't want to say red flags I had but
kind of red flags that I noticed were uh
there were a lot of safes throughout the
world that you could use materials to
crack open I could see the keypad
couldn't interact with it which
playing an Arcane game I understand this
is a they're going for a different style
this is Co-op and I understand how dumb
it would be if someone's sitting there
trying to figure out the code on a
keypad while you're playing with friends
but part of me felt a little bummed that
you know I found a safe and then the
next step wasn't me digging through the
environment looking through notes to try
to figure out what that combination code
might be instead it was just you've got
enough electrical parts to throw them in
here and it'll pop open so that was a
little bit of a bummer the second thing
that kind of stood out to me was that
Mansion they were pushing us to
um at the end of the demo I didn't
finish it but I was trying to there you
had to get to the topmost floor and I
was able to Blink onto the second floor
but then there was a third floor and I
blinked onto the roof to see if I could
open up one of the windows to get in
through that way from what I could tell
I couldn't and and once again like for
an Arcane game that makes me a little
worried
um and again it's it's that thing where
it's like there's three other characters
that can't blame sure like it's like
really it's it's so weird I I think
about it I get it and like I I don't
think it's a bad thing necessarily but
as someone who you know we all love
Arcane games like like you're saying at
the top like I feel like I have to
rewrite my my brain a little bit when it
comes to this game yeah it's the same
way like we asked um Ricardo like are
they trying to make you know jindosh
locks or like you know Clockwork
mansions that kind of stuff in in this
game and he was very kind of upfront
about it and saying like we're gonna
have interesting set pieces but we can't
we're probably not gonna do stuff like
that and it again it's like unlearning
and untraining ourselves what our
expectations for what an Arcane game can
be which is kind of what that studio
requires in a lot of ways like sometimes
a lot of until now it's been like short
steps forward or in different directions
you know going from Dishonored to pray
and then to
um death Loop um but they have been
quite different games and they always
give us something different from what we
expect this one feels like the biggest
step in a different direction and that's
why it's requiring the most like
reconfiguring of our
um expectations and our understandings
but I'm right there with you where it's
like I would love to be able to sneak
around and overhear someone give me
information and climb through a window
but yeah I think I think we're gonna
have to spend some time uh unlearning
those uh desires I will say though I
think the vampire nests uh were peaky
sort of I guess they're talking right
there they're very yeah cool kind of I
don't know felt into inter-dimensional
sort of portal things that you go in and
uh the world's kind of on the on its
head a little bit I thought that was a
really cool separate and I'm but I'd be
interested to see how many of those you
have to do
because I hope it doesn't lose its
luster there's also the Rook which is
basically the nightmare from
um prey where it's a super powered
vampire that the vampire Gods will send
after you if you cause too much of a
fuss and and it's basically unkillable
like you just need to run away
um and try and hide and he will he'll
bring enemies towards you as well so
it's like this push and pull that is
very arcaney yeah I tried to get him to
spawn I was I was trying so hard to piss
off The Vampire gods and I got very
close and then we had to wrap up our
demo because that sounds pretty cool
yeah he was cool he's thick boy he's
like he just looks like Dave but he
still appears in a lightning storm and
you're like oh God uh well then uh
thanks Lance uh it was fun chatting with
you about uh Rachel I'm excited to play
more of it I'm I I think they said they
might do another Hands-On but like all
in Co-op so I hope we get to experience
that if you have any questions about uh
redfull hit us up on twitter.com I'm
Lucy James games Tim I'm Timor H and I'm
Jacob deck thanks for watching